PROFESSOR: Welcome back
to A20 special relativity.
In this last section
of this chapter,
we talked about applications
and implications
of special relativity.
We talked about the
global positioning system.
You all have used GPS
before, be it in your car
when you're trying to
find your way through town
or when you go for a run and
you want to measure how long
and how fast you
actually are running.
The global positioning
system is a set
of satellites all equipped
with atomic clocks.
And they're used for navigation
and have been developed first
under the name of Napster GPS.
And GPS is one of many global
or few global navigation system.
Others are GLONASS, BDS, Galileo
Systems developed in Europe,
in Russia, in Japan, and so.
This picture here
shows you how you
want to view this view of
Earth and then at around 20,000
kilometer, GPS has
about 31 satellites,
which zooms around the Earth.
And as soon as you have
three satellites, which
you can see from
your viewpoint, you
can actually figure out
where that viewpoint is.
Think about each satellite gives
you an information of a sphere.
The cross section between
two spheres is a line.
And if you have three
spheres crossing,
that gives you three-dimensional
information about location
on which you're looking at this.
GPS was-- the first satellites
were launched in 1978.
Again, 31 satellites in
orbit at the time right now.
So how does this work?
So the satellite
transmits information
about position in time
in regular intervals.
It's does have a clock.
They use a specific frequency
or multiple frequency
to send signals.
And then the receiver calculates
how far away the satellite is
and how long it took
the message to arrive
at the place of the receiver.
Again, three satellites are used
to extract the exact location.
However, as you can
imagine, the reason
why I bring this
up in this class
is that we have to
consider effects
of special relativity and
also, general relativity,
as we will discuss
later in this class.
So you have clocks
on the satellites.
And you have identical
clocks on Earth.
And they do tick differently
as we discussed many times
in this class.
If you were to calculate the
effect of special relativity,
the prediction is
that the clocks
take about 7 microseconds a
day slower on the satellite
then compared to
the one on Earth.
However, the satellite
at a higher orbit.
And the gravitational
pull at a higher orbit
is less strong as on Earth.
And that then, as a
result, is the clocks
on the satellites actually run
faster than the ones on Earth.
And that effect is
larger, very larger
than the effect of
special relativity, which
is effect from then just moving
relative to the observer.
The fact is 47
microseconds a day.
And then you can just
calculate the net correction,
which is 38 microseconds
a day, which corresponds
to about 11 kilometers.
Now imagine on your
run and there's
11 kilometer difference a day.
I don't expect you
to run for a day,
but you might run for an hour.
Still the effect
is rather large.
So you want to have a
more precise system.
And therefore, those effects
need to be corrected,
and they are.
They're typically built
in into the electronics
and automatically corrected.
The precision achieved
with GPS system
ranges a little bit based on how
you use the information, what
kind of transceiver you use.
It's in the order of 505
meters to 30 centimeters,
so about this of a distance.
So anywhere on this planet
you can pinpoint your location
by about this with
this precision.
Well, this concludes
the discussion
of implications and applications
in special relativity.